they shoot people and they're not
culpable at all and it's got to stop hi
I'm Tracy Oppenheimer Friesen TV today
we're talking with Mike Putin he's one
of the cast members of the upcoming
Discovery Channel show we'd country its
premiering this Wednesday February 20th
and let's take a look
it's a decades-old battle between cops
dealings and growers using 21st century
science to make the most powerful weed
on earth arguably I just committed a
felony
this is the story of an American at war
with itself Mike thanks for talking with
us glad to be here weed country covers
all angles of the marijuana industry you
have growers like yourself dispensary
owners law enforcement and patients so
what do you as a grower bring to the
table well I think that we give people
sort of a look behind the veil
everybody's got their own conception
about what I do what people like me do
and of course not everybody's the same
and so I think that people get a chance
to see what somebody who's trying to do
the right thing by people does with
marijuana it's like you're a vigilante
you're fighting back against the war on
drugs so talk about your fight a little
bit and some of the obstacles you've had
to overcome well I've used marijuana
since I was 17 years old and I've always
had to try to stay out of trouble with
it it I've been successful at that but
when I realized what it had done for me
and what it could do for other people
and when you when you learn all of the
reasons why marijuana shouldn't be
criminalized you you sort of become
responsible for the information and I
just decided to do something I really
didn't want to live in a world where
where they haul people off to jail for
using a substance that's safer than
alcohol yeah and on the show you see
these law enforcement officers coming in
with camo helicopters automatic weapons
and I know that's not for the show
that's actually what happens so while
the violence it's jihad it's it's ego
it's a jihad and it's a cult that's
exactly what it is it these guys for the
most part see they blur the lines they
blur the lines between cartel and
medical marijuana now if you're gonna go
out in the forest after some cartel guys
I mean I'd root you on to be putting on
that Bart body armor having those
automatic weapons but when you're
talking about a guy who lives in a house
down on Main Street he's not going
anywhere
as a job you know where is that you
could do your intelligence you don't
need to go kicking his door with a SWAT
team and brutalize his family and shoot
their dog and what if they get the wrong
house which happens all the time they
shoot people and they're not culpable at
all and it's got to stop I know you're
really a proponent of medical marijuana
because it helps people and law
enforcement just doesn't see it like
that where do you think the disconnect
comes in you know what I think the
disconnect is and it's gonna make people
angry that I say this but you know
marijuana users the community as a whole
if you want to call it that is a lot
like an iceberg most of it is out of
sight but what can be seen is ominous
and so their correlation causation model
gets all turned on its head because I've
heard police officers say I've never
dealt with a heroin addict that didn't
have marijuana and so they think there's
this progression they think that
marijuana leads to all these other
things so they're more than happy to go
after marijuana users but it does seem
like our culture shifting right now and
on the show you're you're helping a
former NYPD officer I'm not gonna give
too much away but this makes for an
interesting dynamic because you're
helping him the other officers are after
you how did this play out in the show I
have no problem with the fact that he's
the next narcotics officer because he's
a legitimate medical marijuana patient
that was a segment of his life where he
was required to toe the party line
you know everybody uses the Nuremberg
defense so I'm just doing my job
and you know I'll give him a free pass
on that but I think it moves the
conversation I think it does when when
ex narcotics officers are using medical
marijuana to heal themselves because
modern medicine does not have an answer
for them I think that's pretty powerful
but what about your own safety I mean
what's what's stopping you from being
thrown in jail right now nothing the
whim of law enforcement and I'm not
worried about that I'm really not
worried about that I don't want to come
off and sound like oh you know I'm a
martyr I want I'm looking forward to
jail no I don't want to go to jail I
want anybody else to go to jail for
marijuana they were either if nobody
steps up who will I mean I just feel
compelled to step up regardless of the
consequences but you did say the
conversation is moving forward how how
does this show really help with that
well I think the conversation gets moved
forward with the show because it really
is a fair look at at 360 degrees and I
think that the viewer is going to be
able to sort it out from their living
room without the pressure of somebody
elbowing I'm trying to get them to line
up on their side and this this is really
mainstreaming do you think this will be
a big boost for support I think it will
I think it will because I think people
the people suffer for lack of knowledge
that's what it is it's lack of knowledge
people just don't know they've been
indoctrinated they've had campaigns of
reefer madness and 80 years 80 years now
when alcohol prohibition was repealed it
was within 12 years everybody alive knew
what it was like before alcohol
prohibition started and they knew that
alcohol prohibition was worse than the
alcohol being in society and we're 80
years removed from Americans being able
to utilize the marijuana plant in all of
its forms and all that it can do and so
the education campaign is so uphill
because we're we're up against the
disinformation arm of the United States
government we're up against the man in
blue who doesn't lie well well Mike
thanks so much for talking to us thanks
for having me and remember to tune in
this Wednesday February 20th at 10 p.m.
to watch me gun tree on Discovery
Channel Verizon TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you